alerte bennett faute il vient de sortir
un nouveau jeu c'est qui bennett faut
dit le créateur de coopé de clopes mes
amis j'aimerais que mon garçon gamme
aujourd'hui on va essayer de pas paniqué
on va jouer un jeu extrêmement dur qui
s'appelle getting over it littéralement
la traduction de dar hubert invesco se
remettre je préfère la version allemande
c'est extrêmement simple c'est un jeu
dans lequel nous allons jouer à monsieur
qui est dans un pot et qui possède un
marteau le but était simple c'est comme
dans le web et d'en cloque il faut
avancer voilà arrivés au bout de la map
ces partis sans plus tarder comment sous
a ragé alors comme d'après la difficulté
ça va être quoi ça va être d'intégrer
les contrôles c'est chaud i would make
wahaha
on dirait pas mais en vrai le jeu est
hyper bien fait il va falloir intégrer
la physique du jeu pour pouvoir passer
les niveaux ouais on peut se déplacer
comme ça grâce à notre petit marteau
alors le but de jeu littéralement de te
mettre à bout c'est à dire que le mec
l'a dit lui-même [ __ ] est-ce qu'on
peut pas pété larmes je travaille kraft
[Musique]
que je suis content hockey [ __ ] arrête
avec ta musique classique là tu me
traites je lis pas ce que tu dis parce
qu'en fait je parle français ne m'a pas
anglais et je veux juste ne sait trop
passive ce jeu c'est trop facile manqué
la difficulté en fait c'est de se
démerder pour pas retourner en arrière
parce qu'en fait tu contrôles rien ce
que tu fais alors qu'il fait genre tu
que tu comprends ce que tu veux non
[Musique]
alors là c'est dur en fait là je pense
c'est une situation adéquat on prend le
temps de réfléchir bondoukou le score
non non non non c'était pas si un ami à
vous passe vraiment une journée a envoyé
cette vidéo elle termine première ta vie
n'est pas si terrible
[ __ ] un os et aimons ce qu'est ce que
j'aime faire
ok là là pour réfléchir non oh c'était
pas non non non à chaque fois doucement
doucement doucement doucement doucement
ok là mais qu'on peut le faire quand on
sautera sur l'attention c'est bon c'est
bon on attend faut pas revenir en
arrière
attends qu est ce que je fais qu'est ce
que je fais je sais plus quoi faire
oh yes attend les mecs là on a atteint
un summum dans la difficulté comment je
passe sache comment bas faut jeter à ok
de là au numéro yahoo je reviens [ __ ]
non yes allez on y arrive
ah non je vais pas tomber je pas ton nom
alors comment au monde sa a même fait
fausse poussée de l'aude j'ai compris il
faut aller sur celui-là je vous le dis
hein si vraiment je retourne à gauche
fait une dépression nerveuse sous vos
yeux en direct au la vie est dure peut
s'en servir
[Musique]
yes ouais les amis je viens de
comprendre qu'en fait ici il ya un trou
voilà je pensais que c'était plein dans
fête s'est pas plaint je suis juste
débile mais là il faut s'accrocher
[ __ ] de lampes aux attendes il s'agit
il s'agit de ne pas tout gâcher
maintenant
[ __ ] c'est tellement dur il n'ya pas
des spasmes ont manipulé ce marteau au
qu'est ce qu'on fait j'ai besoin d'avoir
fini le jeu c'est comme ça mais kmec mec
respirait plus respirer plus y en a un
qui a inspiré ce pour sa phase et manon
yeah yeahs mais vous imaginez 43 bis
allée au quotidien quand on avance bien
comme ça je suis vraiment heureux et je
suis tellement heureux qu'on perde toute
progression d'un coup allez on est chaud
on se remet dans le bain dans le bar des
gens qui ont confiance en eux après tout
on a fini dax auch iii et c'était le
plus dur de tous donc c'est bon on a
réussi ok alors la suite qu'est ce que
c'est halal à ce quelque chose c'est que
si on tombe je crois qu'on retombe au
tout début du jeu en fait un choix que
c'est ça la blague une escalade en
escalade
comment pas trop le décor mais on est
pas mal ah lalala lalala
c'est un bon ok pas femme on analyse le
parcours c'est normal de faire des
petites erreurs pour moi là on est en
train d'analyser pincourt on est hyper
bien envoyé
mais c'est pas possible ce qui vient de
se passer c'est pas réel c'est dans ma
tête ça n'existe pas il s'est passé quoi
vous sur vos écrans là on en est
vraiment non mais vraiment bah voilà ça
y est
[Applaudissements]
yes à cette fois on y va on est déchaîné
avant si je retourne c'est quand même
tout ça j ai acheté hier je suis sûr
qu'à pas un gameplay youtube ou avec est
tombé de cette manière vraiment je sais
pas pourquoi je sens qu'il ya une sorte
de blog
oh [ __ ] pardon pardon pardon c'est
faux mais parce que quand je pars en
flèche contrôle mal bahamas c'est
incroyable je me rappelle ma masse
musculaire parce que ça j'ai besoin d'un
contrôle du cuir nappa papale ap ap ap
ap ap ap ap à la bal à papa papa
yes yes yes cool un mec je refuse de vos
penderies gameplay aussi nul je veux au
moins arriver au bout du niveau d'après
con mais au final regarder c'est ce que
je disais on a galéré à passer ce prix
est nouvelle mais maintenant qu'on a
intégré la technique est bon on galère
plus trop voilà pourquoi j'ai dix agents
comme tapoter par le [ __ ] de carmat
c'est incroyable c'est incroyable mais
quand tu crois était au plus bas en fait
t'es pas au plus bas yatuu en plus bas
âge postillonne comme un sagouin j'en
peux plus mec je suis pire joueur juste
je craque quoi mais vraiment là je suis
pas bien nerveusement je suis pas bien
[Musique]
ok les a mis là par contre j'ai pas vous
mito à chaque fois savais pas mais à
chaque fois c'est dit [ __ ] deux
minutes de rage vous revenir à ce [ __ ]
d'endroits bien je vais vous dire un
truc le club ça c'est que je rage comme
un fort comme jamais c'est à dire que
j'ai jamais aussi peu avancé en 1h15 sur
un jeu je sais vous avez eu très peur la
vérité c'est que moi aussi qu'est-ce
viège détourner l'attention du jeu de
merde anzin blagues nulles pour pouvoir
gagner alors à temps oh j'ai rien
compris mais tout ce que je sais c'est
que j'ai les larmes aux yeux et que là
on est en train d'y arriver à âmes et je
vous jure que j'aurais essayé je vous
j'aurais essayé mais là je fais les
filles arrivent plus à rien oh [ __ ]
mais regardez c'est fou le jeu m'indique
qu'il faut que j'arrête j'ai plus le
mouvement j'ai perdu mon lit mais j'ai
perdu moulinet c'est comme un mec qu'a
pas fait de vélo pendant dix ans bah
quoi ils montent dessus il s'est en fait
un mauvais exemple je crois que le pire
c'est de se dire que j'ai réussi à les
passer une fois éclat j'arrive plus je
suis une énorme merde toute la france me
regarde en mode mais [ __ ] mais c'est
chiant ta vidéo et que moi je les
regarde et je dis bah ouais mais aussi
mes parents ils m'ont pas fait fort aux
jeux vidéo oh [ __ ] mais dans la ville
armes et la [ __ ] allez vas-y le cas ça
dégage je m'en bats les couilles
maintenant j'y vais
montmagny
[Musique]
karassine
j'ai pu manger bientôt
ces jeux
n'arrive à rien ce gâchis si on réédite
son nom
quant au chic vintage est moche et je
m'attends japonais qui parlent ils
avaient raison vous juste persévérer
[ __ ] [ __ ] comment j'ai fait mec mais
qu on a réussi non
alors ça y est on a passé deux nouvelles
non
on les nourrit nos tirages pendant l'aïd
[Musique]
st